I don't want to be human what hi there
I'm Chris Atkinson Chris is a professor
at the robotics Institute at Carnegie
Mellon University today I'll be breaking
down clips from movie and TV about
artificial intelligence and robotics out
of control robots iRobot detective what
are you doing he said they've all been
programmed with the Three Laws Isaac
Asimov was one of the earliest science
fiction writers who focused on robots
and he came up with this scheme of the
Three Laws yeah I know the Three Laws
perfect circle of protection robots
don't hurt humans but doesn't the second
law state that a robot has to obey any
order given by a human being except if
it causes a violation of the first law
right but the third law states that a
robot can defend itself unless it causes
a violation of the second law and the
first law we have 1,000 robots that will
not try to protect themselves if it
violates a direct order from a human I'm
betting one who will
you saw a robot that somehow it's three
laws were disabled and that left it with
an existential crisis what and which is
sort of similar to what am I supposed to
do next if I you know don't have any
guiding purpose and if it was a case
that robots ran on what we call expert
systems or sets of laws that might
actually be a reasonable way to program
robots you know what they say laws are
made to be broken
but nowadays we're actually programming
robots in a very different way by giving
them lots of training examples and
having them essentially learn parameters
in formulas so that they do the right
thing so we have this mich match between
logical rules and numbers in a formula
so in robot movie after robot movie
they're obsessed with the robots
actively turning against the humans and
started killing human so that I get that
the goddamn robots down far more likely
if the robot will screw up it'll make a
mistake and that mistake will have bad
consequences brother it's a robot
it doesn't need a motive it just has to
be broken a deactivating an Android
Blade Runner really shoot the crazy
robots just coming to attack me yeah
shooting a robot is a potentially a
pretty good way to stop a robot now
there might be parts of its chassis that
you shoot a bullet through it doesn't do
anything
Justin cut any wires doesn't open up a
hydraulic fluid hose so you might have
to shoot it a bunch of times there are
other ways to disable a robot that might
not damage it in the same way for
example there's something called an
electromagnetic pulse which will fry all
at circuits but leave the mechanics
intact Blade Runner is a fantastic movie
has this incredible vision of the future
which by the way we've already caught up
with learning from imitation Terminator
hey buddy got a dead patty near a boy
you pour we're gonna program robots to
have conversations in dialogue and in
many many situations you can anticipate
what happens next but sooner or later
the robots gonna face a situation let's
do it doesn't know what to say
you know the robots gonna have to wing
it in this clip you told was the way to
go you pour a scream came up and English
words were there and it sort of moved a
cursor down and picked one that's only
there for the audience of the movie the
robots aren't going to do that you know
it's all what trikes little transistors
going blip blip blip and it's gonna make
the decision decided our stage a
microsecond programming the new West
world no wait a second she'll do it
again
or fear that's not standard occasionally
in Westworld
you see a black box looks like a fancy
keyboard in which they're sort of
programming various sub behaviors that's
column or primitives it's been this
controversy of do you build up behaviors
from twitch here to twitch there or do
you have a few fundamental behaviors and
then you combine a afford must-have it
turns out you can learn a lot faster if
you combine these fundamental behaviors
rather than adding up a lot of twitches
he calls them memories the old gestures
were just generic movements these are
tied to specific memories this is a
spoiler things will go bad because they
couldn't completely wipe the memory of a
robot memories are purged at the end of
every narrative later still in there
waiting to be able to written you found
a way to access them it turns out in
complex machine so you got lots of
different kinds of memory in lots of
different kinds of places for example
the CPU is going to have a little bit of
memory in it it'll also have something
called cache memory we have what's
called a memory hierarchy there's fast
memory and then they're slower memory
subconscious index if you totally fried
the machine all you'd end up with is a
broken robot so you can't totally wipe
the machine it's the tiny things that
make them seem real robotics lab making
mr. right
you look at that scene you say why is
chemistry happening in a robotics lab
the future of robotics is where we make
materials using chemistry to make soft
materials so that's actually looks very
similar to what goes on in some of my
colleagues labs you know at Carnegie
Mellon I thought showing you these tapes
might have to make you more familiar
with the Droid we video record all our
experiments and in fact often you know
when we press an on button to say do
something that simultaneously turns the
cameras on just so far the rest must be
learned watching video feedback is very
helpful to debug behavior we had some
difficulty with this gross motor
functions before we modified his
cerebral muscular coordination okay so
you just saw some mumbo-jumbo he's
mixing things we'd say about a human who
had a disease we modified a cerebral
muscular coordination and a robot that
doesn't know how to walk gross motor
functions my robots actually fell down
much more than their robot did robot
malfunction
Austin Powers
[Music]
can you design an input to a robot that
will cause it to malfunction or crash
[Music]
only Austin Powers can do that yeah baby
multi-agent robotics Minority Report one
area of research in robotics is what we
call multi agent robotics which is to
get a bunch of robots to work together
[Music]
we model that on humans working together
like a sports team or when we're
searching for somebody lost in the woods
small robots in this clip would seem
very smart and complicated the the dream
in robotics is can we make a lot of
stupid cheap robots that by working
together get the job done
what we saw in this clip is they were
usually some kind of imaging radar to
figure out where people are likely to be
Tom Cruise hidden in the bathtub that
water shields him from radar as you saw
but it also tries to hide his thermal
signature so he's hotter than everything
else around him and any kind of infrared
imaging would have found him that's why
he dumped ice in the water as well but
you know if the robots have any kind of
camera they could have just looked down
and there's Tom Cruise so I think we're
gonna have to do a little better than
that if we're gonna hide from the robots
thermal vision Westborough the
west-world clip is using what we call
thermal imaging far infrared imaging
where you essentially scan see an image
of the temperature of things that are
out there
when the human got next to something
that was much hotter the movie tried to
suggest that that would hide the human
that's actually probably not the case
because the human isn't any less hot and
as long as the image doesn't do what we
call bloom and the whole thing saturate
that robot should have been able to see
the human just as well human limitations
Battlestar Galactica the five of us
designed you to be as human as possible
I don't want to be human I want to see
gamma rays
I want to hear x-rays and I want to I
want to smell dark matter it's highly
unlikely robots are gonna complain about
their bodies what they might complain
about is our crappy computational
hardware my can't even express these
things properly a lot of it gets back to
how do we build computers and right now
for largely historical reasons we
separate out the thinking part we'll
call that the processor and the memory
part and in order to really think about
things we've got to move everything in
the memory part into the processor so it
can process it and it turns out that's
really slow and if you want to save
stuff you got to move it back and that's
really slow I'm so broken then whose
fault is that
it's my makers fault google has
something called a TPU which they're
optimizing to run something called
neural networks and they're building
bucket loads of these things and they're
very very different from standard
computers but I know I want to reach out
with something other than these
prehensile paws I do believe that the
way we build computers now is going to
change completely in many ways I'm a
machine and I could know much more if
the robots want to help us do a better
job at that more power to a robotics lab
Rising Sun
why do we have guys in gold suits I
don't know why you'd wear gold suits you
certainly in a clean room where some
kind of suit so your dandruff doesn't
ruin the chips they look ridiculous
captain Connie the people making the
movie said we got to get us some
cool-looking robots but I've been told
by reliable sources but only you have
the next generation of technology to do
this kind of work so they actually
reached out to what was then the leg lab
which was at that time at MIT you're
looking at early robots that eventually
became Boston Dynamics I'm getting out
to a lot more Dodger games lately the
robot on the boom I believe was a yuna
room which it was a kangaroo like robot
so the 3d biped is quite famous it was
you know one of the first robots that
didn't have a sort of protective system
to keep it from falling down but you're
reliable sources are wrong and it did a
lot of amazing things walk run it even
did flips in contrast the robot you saw
earlier inside that that building was on
a boom and it runs in a circle what did
I think of next design Bicentennial man
have you given any thought whatsoever as
to what age you'd like to be officially
I am 62 years old let's take off 25
years what do you say 15 20
they use soft materials to make the face
of the robot soft materials typically do
what we call creep over long periods of
time the animatronic figures such as the
Disney presidents and whatnot all begin
to sag
just keeping you and you toes I don't
have any toes a big problem with robot
skin is after a while it gets worn it
gets cuts it sags it's actually a big
problem because you if you load it up
with sensors and wires it's a million
dollar piece of skin and fixing it is a
big problem but otherwise it's pretty
much how you make a robot face you have
some mechanism and you cover it with
some soft gooey stuff origami
transformers
[Music]
there are a lot of robots out there who
want to build origami robots robots that
can reconfigure themselves by folding
that turns out to be a great way to
build robots Oh No another area of
Robotics is more like traditional
origami where you have a flat sheet and
you have a folding pattern and that
makes a three-dimensional robot why is
it a good idea to start things from a
flat sheet you can use any printing
technology you want to lay down things
like surfaces or materials but most of
these folding robots are on a smaller
scale for structural reasons so they're
on the meter or centimeter scale rather
than the hundred or tens of meter scale
big guys big guys a big done in robotic
insects black mirror call any collapse
disorder we we still don't know what's
behind it bees themselves were virtually
extinct so what all ad eyes do is
effectively standing for them this clip
is very close to the truth in that
people are trying to build robot insects
right now they can build things they're
almost as small as a bee and they can
fly
we simply set the behavior and leave
them to it they need rudimentary pattern
recognition in order to locate
compatible flora navigate they even
construct these hives themselves
they they reproduce yeah each hive is a
replication pole I was entertained by
the hives which had these sort of
squarish honey combs it's like a 3d
printer basically they also had a little
bit of confusion about reproduction they
create duplicates of themselves create
more hives and spread out exponentially
they seem to suggest that there's this
big 3d printer that's churning them out
which I wouldn't really call
reproduction I'd call that production
machine it's necessary no.10 is it would
have an environmental catastrophe
these were dying out are we gonna have
to make robots and big factories in the
future or are we gonna have find a
similar way to just grow new robots it's
a big issue for robots radiation
Chernobyl
all right let's take this easy forward
one meter reverse one last one
did you lose the signal it's not a
signal it's the vehicle
instead a problem with high-energy
radiation is you have chips circuits
which rely on every part working the
higher energy particle comes in and
damages it knocks out a trace or two and
the whole thing stops working and they
should have known that that was gonna
happen I'm a little surprised at that I
wrote what was never going to work an
implication of this is why does military
electronics cost so much they anticipate
high levels of radiation if you're
fighting in the midst of a nuclear war
an amount of gamma radiation penetrates
everything the particles literally shred
the circuits in microchips apart all
their equipment needs to be read hard as
well
it means the circuit is much more likely
to keep working in the presence of
high-energy radiation and that makes it
fantastically expensive I'm surprised at
how good the old stuff was at predicting
what's gonna happen a lot of robots this
ain't Hollywood I love Hollywood you
know give me more robot movies it's very
inspirational let's go out there and
watch more movies